[Música]
tudo bem
sombra queixa ao falar sobre
entrincheiramento ambiental pra vocês e
eu queria falar pra vocês que até o ano
de 2003
eu trabalhava com treinamento e
consultoria e numa das viagens aqui para
o interior da bahia
junto com o parceiro um colega de
trabalho fizemos um enfim um diagnóstico
no ano a associação e eu lembro que na
estrada às 20 30 da noite mais ou menos
naquele bate papo informal ele falou
algo pra mim quebrou completamente o
estado é pessoal e profissional até
aquele momento eu já estou muito
acostumado a liderar equipes a trabalhar
com o treinamento desenvolvimento humano
até realmente promovendo e fazendo
acontecer tanto pessoal quanto no
profissional quanto naquele dia à noite
ele falou pra mim é andré
eu acho que você precisa desenvolver
mais o seu perfil de liderança eu não
vejo você como líder e se você continuar
com o mesmo perfil que você possui hoje
em cinco anos você vai estar fora do
mercado de trabalho ou menos que isso
naquele dia naquele momento naquela
noite eu lembro que eu cheguei no hotel
do inter b e de lá a mesma felicidade em
feira de santana e comecei a refletir
muito nos dias
nas semanas e nos meses que se passaram
eu tinha muito forte em mim
até aquele instante que uma trincheira
por exemplo era um campo que me dava
duas possibilidades uma possibilidade de
defesa
a possibilidade de ataque e até ali uma
trincheira mental pra minha trincheira
que utilizava no meu nome minha mente
inconsciente na minha mente consciente
era um local então estava me preparando
para o ataque
a partir daquele instante eu comecei a
refletir muito se realmente aquele
feedback é um feedback construtivista um
feedback negativo
e acreditem eu deixei ao a se perder
quase seis meses da minha carreira
simplesmente porque alguém de fora me
falou que não tinha perfil então fiquei
aprisionado na trincheira do
escondimento
depois de um tempo começando e
ressignificando aquela história
eu decidi e perceber claramente que não
passava de um feedback negativo um
feedback que não era construtivo e o
feedback que não tinha o objetivo de
engrandecer o meu perfil profissional e
principalmente pessoal que é que eu fiz
eu comecei a mergulhar cada dia mais a
cada dia mais em bibliografias e livros
e uma série de outros atrativos e
entende basicamente que a libertação
para um potencial profissional e pessoal
se dá através de uma série de níveis que
nós chamamos de níveis neurológicos
a base para o sucesso de qualquer
profissional está completamente ligado
ao sne alinhamento dos seus níveis
neurológicos
então a partir dali eu comecei a
entender que eu tinha todos os recursos
que eu precisava para realizar qualquer
tipo de mudança na minha vida e na minha
carreira e esses recursos estavam aqui
na minha mente principalmente no meu
nome minha mente criativa no meu lado
criativo no meu lado emocional no meu
lado relacionamento no meu lado humano
última de self 2
então desde aquele instante eu decidir
potencializar eu disse de utilizar
aquele feedback negativo ao meu favor e
potencializar através de ações que eram
práticas em prol de um objetivo de vida
e um objetivo de carreira então eu
comecei a estudar e perceber claramente
as sete níveis da europa eo alinhamento
neurológico o primeiro nível
claro é o ambiente o primeiro nível que
tinha que estar muito bem alinhado o
primeiro nível que tinha que tá muito
bem estabelecido era o meio ambiente
o meu ambiente formal o meu trabalho eo
meu ambiente informal a minha casa eu
comecei a perceber claramente que eu
precisava verdadeiramente está no local
em que sente-se prazer e percebesse
possibilidade de desenvolvimento locais
físicos
então a partir dali comecei a me
preparar
e aí motivar trazer para o self 2 trazer
promocional projetos de vida e de
carreira planejamento que poucas pessoas
fazem planejamento de carreira que
poucas pessoas fazem aliás nós vamos
planejar a carreira depois já passamos
20 e 30 anos ea nossa carreira muito
curta porque todos os dias passa muito
rápido
o primeiro pilar alinhamento do meio
ambiente informal e do meio ambiente
formal profissional e pessoal a partir
dali eu comecei a perceber que grato
feliz e tranquilo na minha informalidade
ou formalidade ambiental eu poderia
melhorar os meus comportamentos a mesma
atitude se desenvolver novas habilidades
se aquele feedback da foto de liderança
me abalou até aquele momento algum
significado poderia tirar dali algum
significado poderia perceber através da
queda daquele daquela conversa naquele
bate papo
então comecei a precisar reunir
habilidades competências e desenvolver
alguns papéis que até aquele momento eu
realmente não tinha por exemplo
competências interpessoais de
conhecimento a busca de aprender a
aprender entender que o aprendizado
constante
tá aprender a ser aprender a me vestir
profissional a incorporar um
profissional aprender a ler a buscar
conhecimento e o principal entender e
aprender a conviver com o outro o
sucesso das relações profissionais estão
pautadas no relacionamento e está muito
ligado às questões de comportamento
isso foi em 2002 2003 quando era muito
jovem e tive que aprender na prática o
meio ambiente completamente alinhado com
os meus comportamentos focados e
habilidades e novas atitudes
nós vamos para o campo de capacidades o
que é que eu preciso fazer em nível
prático para que eu possa me superar
quais nichos de mercado após alcançar ou
quais treinamentos quais curso eu posso
buscar para que eu possa me aprimorar
cada vez mais e anular aquele
entrincheiramento do medo e do
esconderijo e potencializar a liberdade
o poder
e há possibilidade que o mercado me dava
bebida fonte do be regionalismo bebida
fonte do condicionamento
quanto mais eu treinava mais esperto
ficava quanto mais eu treinava mais me
senti desenvolvido quanto mais estudava
mais a fundo eu queria estudar ea partir
daí aquele feedback começou a ficar lá
atrás cada vez mais atrás ambiente
completamente alinhado os comportamentos
aliados às capacidades aflorando eu fui
para as minhas crenças e valores em que
verdadeiramente acreditava
quais são os pontos fundamentais na via
na minha vida até aquele momento que
formavam pilares de crenças
possibilitadoras quais são os meus
valores quais eram os meus valores
éticos e morais
e como eu poderia utilizá los juntamente
com o meio ambiente com meu
comportamento e com as minhas
capacidades técnicas até aquele momento
profissionais que não possuem valores
éticos morais muito bem ancoradas no seu
sistema integrado eles praticamente
estão fora do mercado porque o mercado
hoje é relacionamento sempre foi e
sempre será
nós estamos na era do conhecimento nessa
área nós vamos mergulhar cada vez mais o
conhecimento muito se dá através das
pessoas
as pessoas que passam por você todos os
dias
ambiente completamente alinhado
juntamente com os comportamentos as
capacidades as minhas crenças e valores
eu fui pro meu campo de identidade o que
eu sou eo que eu quero ser a minha
missão identidade quem é o meu mentor de
carreira
quem são as pessoas que são os
profissionais que podem inspirar a minha
carreira
comecei a perceber que eu não precisava
e não podia me inspirar apenas em
profissionais que estão no mercado e eu
comecei a me inspirar em profissionais
que estão em várias áreas mercadológicas
desde a música ao teatro
a escrita leitura ao mundo corporativo a
família a religião eu comecei a perceber
que eu poderia criar a minha identidade
me inspirando e bebendo da fonte de
várias áreas
completamente diferentes porque o meio
ambiente já estava aliado o meu
comportamento já pedi a um processo de
produtividade
as minhas capacidades estavam sendo
desenvolvidas e as minhas crenças e
valores se fortaleciam enquanto isso o
que aconteceu a partir daí meus amigos o
meu mapa de realidade se abriu e eu
deixei de ter uma visão apenas frontal e
passei a ter uma visão holística eu
comecei a entender o mundo como ele é
comecei a entender o mundo não só como o
processo mercadológico mas entender o
mundo através de mim através da minha
identidade a quem mais eu sirvo nesse
mundo mercadológico e como eu posso
fortalecia minha identidade
transformando ajudando e principalmente
apoiando as pessoas a construírem suas
metas alcançarem suas metas e porque não
a superar metas todos os dias a partir
desse instante com o meio ambiente
alinhado aos meus comportamentos as
minhas capacidades as minhas crenças e
valores ea minha identidade sendo
completamente estabelecida eu fui para o
meu campo de afiliação time mercado se
vence em conjunto
eu não posso pensar individual eu
preciso pensar em grupo pensar em um
time
a partir do instante que nós começamos a
perceber que através de alianças e
parcerias estratégicas e através do rap
porta da conexão da empatia dos se
entender pelo olhar
eu poderia ir galgando degraus cada vez
maiores e ajudando as pessoas a irem
comigo eu percebi que o campo
neurológico nível neurológico de
afiliação talvez fosse um dos mais
importantes para que eu pudesse me
desenvolver como pessoa e como
profissional
e aí a cereja do bolo com os meus níveis
neurológicos completamente alinhados eu
vou para o campo maior
o campo da espiritualidade aqui é mais
nocivo até onde eu posso ir com minha
verdadeira missão aqui nesse planeta
terra sete níveis neurológicos
completamente alinhados através de um
insight que eu tive de um feedback
completamente negativo a 15 16 anos
atrás
o grande questionamento que eu deixo
para vocês é quantas milhares e milhões
de pessoas no mundo inteiro não travam a
sua vida não travam seus projetos não
ficam estagnados
durante décadas simplesmente porque
ouvem uma palavra mal colocada num carro
na casa na escola e aquilo ali causará
nela uma crença limitante sabe uma
prisão em que vai afastá lá dos seus
sonhos dos seus projectos dos
planejamentos não vai deixar sua visão
de mundo se expandir e talvez ali nós
temos perdido muitos sonhos muito
planejamentos muitas vidas que poderiam
deixar de ser transformadas
a partir do momento e que você entende
que todo recurso que você precisa para
realizar qualquer tipo de mudança na sua
vida e na sua carreira na vida das
pessoas que você mais ama nesse mundo
você basicamente sai de si por um
instante se enxerga de fora enxerga
imparcial e começa a perceber que você é
um misto do seu ambiente físico e
corporativo
você é um misto dos seus comportamentos
você é um misto das suas capacidades
você o mixto das suas crenças e valores
da sua identidade do seu processo de
afiliação de pertencimento e
principalmente da sua espiritualidade
sete níveis lógicos e neurológicos que
ando em conjunto que se completam e que
se alinhados darão a você uma trincheira
de possibilidades uma trincheira onde
você vai conseguir enxergar todo
o campo de atuação para que dali em
diante você consiga entender quais são
as melhores possibilidades
quais são os melhores caminhos quais são
os melhores recursos que você dispõe
naquele momento para que você consiga
fazer diferente e para que você consiga
fazer a diferença na sua vida na vida
das pessoas que você mais ama e
principalmente no mercado no qual você
está inserido o nosso mundo é um mundo
dinâmico o nosso mundo é o mundo
competitivo é um mundo instável é o
mundo acirrado é um mundo egoísta é o
mundo muitas vezes ingrato e cada um de
nós pode ser vetor primordial para a
mudança desse pólo para a mudança dessa
mentalidade para que nós possamos
efetivamente fazer algo diferente algo
melhor
e daqui a um dois cinco dez 15 20 e 30
anos
começamos a perceber que os resultados
começa a mudar a partir de cada um de
nós
eu entendi isso através de um feedback
negativo
não deixe para entender isso no dia que
alguém apontar para vocês é que você é
capaz
não deixe para entender isso no dia que
falar pra você que você não vai chegar a
algum lugar
muito pelo contrário e desperte seu
potencial agora entendo o seu potencial
e desperte seu potencial a partir de
agora você é vetor de mudança
você é a mudança que você precisa
verdadeiramente a partir de agora se não
com o autor mas o autor da tua vida a
outra sua história com foco nos
objetivos da sua família e os seus
valores
o trabalho do seu projecto e daquilo
tudo que você acredita eu entendi isso e
graças a deus consigo ter bons
resultados aqui no coração e
principalmente aqui na minha mentalidade
muito obrigado a todos vocês
[Aplausos]